欸，你可能想不到，一家藝術博物館居然能靠「安全訓練」賺錢，還賺了數百萬美元，客戶都是財星500強企業。
博物館賺錢不稀奇，辦展覽、賣周邊商品嘛。但安全訓練？這聽起來有點跳tone，而且還是財星500強的客戶，他們怎麼會買單這種服務？
這就是有趣的地方。這家叫COVE的公司，是美國俄亥俄州托雷多藝術博物館在2017年成立的。他們把藝術領域的「視覺素養」訓練，轉化成教員工怎麼識別工作場所的危險。
等等，視覺素養跟工安有什麼關係？這兩者感覺風馬牛不相及。一般公司要搞安全訓練，就請工安顧問來講法規、流程，或者做些實作演練。這博物館的做法，到底特別在哪？
這就是它「出乎意料」的地方。一般人想到安全訓練，可能就覺得枯燥、八股。但COVE的做法很巧妙，他們不是直接教你「這個不能碰，那個要注意」，而是從藝術品的觀察切入。
怎麼說呢？讓我來想像一下，是帶員工去博物館看畫，然後說：「你看這幅畫裡有個細節，如果你在工廠看到類似的狀況，是不是就要小心？」是這樣嗎？
其實有點像。他們是透過訓練人們提升對環境的「視覺敏銳度」，讓你更能注意到那些平常可能習以為常、卻潛藏危險的細節。COVE的主席兼總經理Doug Pontsler就說，人很容易對周遭環境習以為常，久了就「視而不見」。
所以他們是想訓練員工，把工作環境當成藝術品一樣去「觀察」？這點子是蠻特別啦，但真的能有效降低工安事故嗎？財星500強企業會花錢買這種「感覺有點玄」的訓練？
原文有提到，COVE的效益是雙重的。它不僅確實幫助減少了工作場所的事故，而且在博物館面臨財務壓力和參觀人數下降的時候，為他們創造了數百萬美元的收入。托雷多藝術博物館的館長Adam M. Levine就說，他們不只看重營收潛力，更在乎藝術專業能幫助人們更安全。
嗯，既然有具體營收數字，那表示效果應該還不錯。那這個「視覺素養」的訓練，具體是怎麼操作的？是像上課一樣，還是有什麼特別的活動？
他們主要採用「工作坊」模式，而且很多工作坊就直接在博物館裡舉行。帶領這些工作坊的，都是有豐富EHS（環境、健康與安全）經驗的專業人士。除了開放式的公開班，他們也為特定客戶舉辦專屬工作坊。
把博物館當成訓練場地，這倒蠻新鮮的。那對於中小企業主或主管來說，能從中學到什麼？我們不可能把員工都帶去博物館上課吧？
這就是重點了。你可以從這個案例中看到，他們把「視覺素養」這種看似跟安全無關的軟實力，巧妙地包裝成解決企業痛點的高價值服務。就算你不是博物館，也可以思考：自己或團隊有什麼「非傳統」的專業，能用來解決客戶的問題？
意思是，不要只想到提供傳統的解決方案，而是去思考客戶潛在的、自己都沒發現的需求，然後用一種意想不到的方式去滿足它？
沒錯。像美術館的視覺素養，如果只拿來「鑑賞藝術」，那服務對象就有限。但把它延伸到「提升危險察覺能力」，客群就擴大到所有有工安需求的企業，而且服務的附加價值也大大提升了。
我懂了，就是重新定義服務的價值，把看似平凡的東西，用創新的方法包裝成高利潤的解決方案。那對於一般上班族來說，這個概念能用在哪？
其實，我們工作中也常有「視而不見」的時候，尤其是在重複性高、例行性的工作上。很多錯誤和疏忽，可能就是因為習慣了，所以對環境中的細微變化不夠敏銳。
所以意思就是，不管做什麼工作，都要保持一點「新鮮感」，訓練自己去察覺那些平常容易忽略的細節？比如程式設計師，不能只寫程式，還要像個藝術家一樣，去觀察程式碼中的「危險訊號」？
可以這麼理解。讓自己對工作環境保持一種「好奇」和「審視」的狀態，而不是被動接受。這樣或許就能在問題還小的時候，就先發現它。
這點其實不容易做到，人本來就容易惰性。不過，這個案例確實提醒我們，很多時候，創新的靈感可能來自於看似不相關的領域。
好像也提醒了我們，只要換個角度看問題，再平凡的專業，都可能找到它「魔法」般的應用。